in her son Russian forces that occupied
the city left months ago but they are
still active just on the other side of
the river behind me
the fighting blackouts and food
shortages have pushed many people to
leave
and for the ones who have stayed
uncertainty remains as the country
prepares for fighting to intensify ahead
of what ukrainians expect will be a
major Russian offensive in the spring
is
so one year after the war started we
came to her son to see what's next along
the front lines in Ukraine
her son which was largely spared damaged
during the occupation has now become a
combat zone Ukrainian forces have taken
up positions inside the city where
there's more cover from incoming fire
and are launching artillery at the
Russians across the river the Russians
are shooting back and the sound of
shells is now in constant here
Ukrainian forces deny firing from within
the city
um
we've heard the sound of outgoing
artillery fire in central hair salon
during multiple reporting trips
the fighting is unlikely to stop anytime
soon Ukrainian forces have remissions
onto the far side of the river but
reclaiming the huge swaths of territory
that Russians still control on the far
bank is a tall order
Bosman is a Ukrainian soldier in the
trenches near the deniper rivers
though her son is not a strategic Hub it
is symbolically important for Moscow it
was the only Regional capital Russia
captured last year so it was Central to
any claims that Kremlin made that the
war had been a success but there was
fierce resistance here from the first
days of the occupation
Tatiana corlenko was one of the Harrison
residents who took to the streets
[Music]
despite the protests Moscow took steps
to turn Harrison into a Russian city
boys
now a Ukrainian flag again flies over
the regional government building in this
Square where thousands of people greeted
Ukrainian soldiers
[Applause]
many have fled since those triumphant
scenes today Central hair salon is a
ghost town and bears scars from Russian
Artillery fire over the last few months
at tropinka hospital in central hair
salon only a skeleton staff remains but
doctors say there's enough medicine and
workers for the hospital to
functions
doctors are also facing other challenges
including treating patients with
injuries from Russian Artillery
[Music]
um
foreign
so after a year of War residents of hair
salon are still unsure what lies ahead
many have relatives on the other side of
the river in occupied territory and have
no idea when they might see them again
on the ground neither Russia nor Ukraine
has achieved a major breakthrough since
your son was liberated last year
for now fighting is concentrated in
Ukraine's East where a costly Battle of
attrition could shape the war to come
with Russia using its Manpower advantage
to slowly claw back territory
Ukraine is pushing Western allies for
weapons that would help them retake
territory this spring
and any negotiations to end the war
still appear to be a long way off
for the people who remain in her song
they know that even if Ukraine makes
progress in the war rebuilding will take
years